hello welcome to the NewsHour we begin
with breaking news coming out of Ukraine
where 16 people have been killed in a
Russian missile attack on a market in
the east of the country Let's cross over
to Rob McBride who joins us now on the
phone line this news just developing
really Robert tell us what you know
about this attack
that's right these details have just
been coming in they're confirmed from
President Vladimir zelenski's office
this attack
um happened uh sometime earlier uh today
it was on a the town of costantinika
this is a relatively small town it's in
the Donetsk region it's about 20
kilometers or so from the um Eastern
front and we are being told by the
ukrainians that it was uh it came under
some sort of attack either shelling or
missiles right in the center of the town
in a market area where there were stalls
there were people out in this area also
a couple of different shops including a
pharmacy uh were caught in the blast and
we have initial reports of 16 people uh
being killed it's understood that they
are civilians that many more though
um are injured these are the reports we
are getting so far and we've had a
comments from president zielinski
himself describing this as The Audacity
Of evil he says the brazenness of
wickedness and also utter in humanity
and we are now starting to see images on
social media of what appears to be
although we haven't uh verified this and
corroborated it but it would appear to
be
um close circuit television fixed
cameras uh of an explosion in a
Marketplace a number of buildings on
fire afterwards and as I said the
details of this are still emerging we
understand as well as 16 people killed a
number of others have been injured and
of course Rob this comes as no
coincidence at the same time as a senior
diplomatic figure arrives in the
Ukrainian capital
yeah that's right I mean we are seeing
uh a visit by Anthony blinken here the
U.S Secretary of State he arrived on a
visit the details of the visit were kept
confidential were kept secret until he
was actually arrived Inky if he's in
Kiev at the moment uh meeting with
senior members of the government uh it's
the third visit that he personally has
made uh has made to Ukraine it follows
on from a visit possibly by President
Biden in February of uh this year uh but
uh Anthony blinken has been meeting with
the officials here he is likely to
announce the uh a new Aid package of up
to a billion uh us uh dollars and other
help in Ukraine's in Ukraine's war and
it also follows another night of attacks
in the Odessa region where we saw her
again
um Russian drones targeting the uh the
uh at grain exporting facilities close
to the Danube River it's this area where
River ports from Ukraine export food out
of Ukraine with the cancellation of the
Black Sea grain deal a couple of months
ago he's been finding alternative routes
of getting its grain out to the world so
it does come at a fairly significant
moment here we have blinken's visit but
as I said this does seem to be a
significant attack in the east of the
east of the country the town of
costantinika as we know so far 16 people
killed but many others we know are
injured for the moment Robert Brad
thanks very much for that update Rob and
we'll get more from Rob as the NewsHour
progresses and we get more information